Hi, Corey D'Augustine here from the "In The Studio" session.
Nope, not a "session."
Take two.
Hi, Corey D'Augustine here from the "In The Studio" series.
I want to wish you a Happy New Year, and I hope you made a New Year's Resolution to paint more in 2018.
I want to let you know that we will be here
with a Live Q&A session
Wednesday, February 7th at 3:00 p.m. New York time.
I will be responding to some of the questions
left over from our last session in September,
live questions, obviously, and if you can't
make that session please feel free to drop
a question down in the comments section below.
I'll do my best to get to it.
A couple of questions that we will be featuring include one from Cecelia Beck who asks about
de Kooning's paintings and how they fare over time.
De Kooning used some unorthodox paint
mixtures as you know, and we'll talk about
some of the ramifications of that as his paintings age.
Argendiego asks about how to increase the
canvas tension after painting on it with a
palette knife, stretching a canvas having a nice taut
surface, losing some of that tautness by scraping, etc.
How do you get it back?
I have a couple of good ideas for you.
Another viewer asks "Why not paint like yourself?"
In fact, we touched on this a bit last time, but it's a really important question.
In fact, you can't do anything but paint like yourself
as much as you might try.
Anyway, we'll delve back into that and explore
that in a little bit more depth.
So again, that's Wednesday February 7th at 3:00 p.m. New York time.
Please click on Subscribe below and also click
on the bell icon that will let you know when
we go live, so you don't miss us.
I look forward to seeing you then.